اذا طهر ازمه المناخ بالفعل حيويه وملح
والتمويل الطارئ مطلوب بشده لكن الظروف
الدوليه الاقتصاديه والسياسيه لا تساعد
كثيرا فقمه كوب 27 مع الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا التي مضى عليها ثمانيه اشهر
مسببه ازمه طاقه خانقه وتضخما عالميا
يزداد سوءا ضغط الحرب في اوكرانيا ونقص
الطاقه المرتبطي بها على المخاوف المناخيه
الحكومات قليقه بشان انكماش الاقتصادي
وانهارت بعض التحالفات الرئيسيه المتبنيه
لقضايا المناخ وهي والات الحرب اذا بحسب
الرئيس المصري
انا باتكلم تحديدا هنا على الازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
وبوجه نداء ان سمحتوا لي
بكم ومعكم من اجل ان تتوقف هذه الحرب
من اجل ان تتوقف هذه الحرب
من فضلكم
نحن
كدول
اقتصادها
مش قوي
عن الكثير جدا من تبعات
ازمه قرون سنتين
وتحملناها
والان يعني ايضا من هذه الحرب
ولكن انا بتكلم هنا عشان العالم كله اتصور
انه بيعاني من هذه الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا الدول على اعاده
الانبعاثات الى الوراء بالعوده الى الوقود
الاحفوري والفحم تنقل صحيفه
على الفحم سينمو وسيتحرق اوروبا 220 مليون
طن اضافي من الفحم مقارنه بما كانت
توقعاتنا قبل الحرب اي ما يعادل لك اكثر
من نصف مليار تونس من ثاني اكسيد الكربون
كما يتزايد استخدام الفحم في البلدان التي
يتنامى فيها الطالب على الطاقه تسع اسواق
اسيويه كبيره مما في ذلك الصين والهند
يمثل الفحم ما لا يقل عن ثلث الوقود
المستخدم لتوليد الكهرباء
عن الصين وهي اكبر ملوث في العالم فهي
تسعى الى تحقيق التوازن بين اهداف المناخ
والحاجه الى امن الطاقه ومن دونها لن يكون
العالم قادرا على تحقيقه هدف واحد فاصل
خمسه درجه مئويه والكلام لانطونيو بوترش
ستكون الاشعارات التي سترسلها قمه مجموعه
العشرين التي ستعقد في اندونيسيا يومي
الخامس عشر والسادس عشر من نوفمبر حاسمه
بالنسبه للقرارات التي اعتمدها كوب 27
لكنها ثقه كبيره في قمه شرم الشيخ لايجاد
الحلول للكوارث المناخيه التي تتسارع
وترتها والتي تسببت في ارتفاع عدد الضحايا
والنازحين بالاضافه الى الخسائر المديه
التي تقدر بالمليارات
من اجل الاجابه عن تلك الاسئله
والرد على شواغل الملايين حول العالم
الذين يعانون الان
اكثر من اي وقت مضى من كوارث مناخيه
تتصارع وترتها
وتزداد حدتها على نحو غير مسبوق
يوما بعد يوم
في شتى انحاء كوكبنا
فما تلبس ان تنتهي كارثه في مكان ما حتى
تبدا اخرى في مكان اخر
مخالفه وراءها الاف الضحايا والمصابين
والنازحين